[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
scott hansen nfl network's nfl red zone
host and uh they will celebrate the
200th show this weekend fans can watch
all seven hours of live football
and see every touchdown from every game
sunday afternoons
throughout the regular season and scott
joining us
after of course the busy schedule that
he has where he works one day
a week and scott joins us now on the
program
congratulations on uh approaching 200
episodes of uh nfl red zone
dan i appreciate it thank you i i tuned
in the last segment oh
and i heard you guys talking about
bladder integrity
and that 200 episodes was just a good
year for you on sportscenter i thought i
tuned i thought i was late i thought i
missed my slot here
you're playing my song all right how
often do you go to the bathroom
over a seven hour period zero times
see i've taken one bathroom break
in the last probably eight plus years
this is season 12
of nfl red zone and i took one bathroom
break and i was playing hurt that day
so i had i had an excuse but nope
i do not go to the bathroom for all
seven hours i would like to see a best
bladder competition with you and andrew
siciliano
so i think siciliano told me he takes
breaks i think he does take one break a
show
but i i'm sure he'll have him on and and
he can tell you that for sure
i mean i thought you're going to see me
and kuiper because
kuiper's obviously famous or infamous
for never going to the bathroom during
the first round of the nfl draft
so but i wonder though isn't it
interesting where people will
i'm going to guess that's one of the top
questions that you're asked about your
job
you you hit it 100 there's not a day
that goes by
people want to talk about me the iron
bladder
that's my fantasy football my fantasy
team name is the aaron blatters
more than they want to talk football
with me and i think it's because of this
dan
it's everybody can relate to it
tons of people millions of people watch
nfl red zone they sit down with their
beverages and their snacks they're all
fired up
we get through the first two or three
hours and nature calls for everybody
they get up from their couch they don't
want to because we don't do commercials
so they think the next great touchdown
could be right around the corner
but they eventually give in get up go to
the bathroom come back and i'm still
talking
and they're like well when when does
this guy take a pee
and everyone is fascinated by it and
everyone dan comes up to me and thinks
they're the first
person that's ever asked me hey you know
me and my wife watch the show
and we wonder when do you take a lead
they all think they're the first one so
i
i try and humor everyone it's it's my
career has been
reduced to the man with the most bladder
integrity on national television i also
wondered about this
when you're doing your job you know
because we would get criticized on
sportscenter
because of the highlights we would pick
they thought
keith oberman and i picked the
highlights and then they'd get upset
or hey you never show us in a positive
light you don't show
longer highlights with us like you do
the yankees of the red sox
what kind of criticism do you get on the
red zone
with highlights the you know frequency
and the length
yeah i'm so glad you said that because i
thought we were the only ones
there's look seven hours commercial free
football
every touchdown from every game there's
a lot to like right and everyone
loves it by and large but if there's a
negative to it
it's we have done our jobs so well i
think
that we have spawned a generation of
wannabe
television executives because everybody
thinks they know
where we're supposed to be at the moment
that we're supposed to be there
and everyone thinks their team is
getting slighted and everyone thinks
that you know i hate this team or i hate
that team or whatever
and i'm like guys no one no one in the
country
wants to show you more football than the
guy you're listening to right
now trust me on that and the thing is
they're watching nfl red zone
i'm watching eight nine games at the
same time
so they've got to trust us to make the
decision i'm so glad that you said you
guys got that grief on sportscenter
because
it's the one negative that i hear and
i'm like you're not going to miss
anything
trust us you're not going to miss it
give me the fan base that makes you a
little nervous
you want me to name names here
okay the big ones right the dallas
cowboy fans
always think one way or another you know
that that
and i love the cowboys like i love all
32 teams
the new england patriots have gotten a
little entitled uh
through the years i think the new
england patriots yeah the fans they
they've gotten a little entitled which
is kind of funny because tom brady
told me a few super bowls ago he told me
when he's on the buy or he's playing on
monday night football or thursday night
football or
wednesday afternoon football he he
watches nfl red zone when he's not
playing on sunday
and he says he loves it and i'm like you
guys if it's good enough for tom
it should be good enough for y'all the
challenge of this year
given interchangeable lineups uh
you know just trying to figure out you
think this game's on a sunday now it's
on a monday or tuesday
how has this year been different for you
yeah well look it with with covid we've
had to change things like you guys have
had to change things like we've all had
to change our lives
so imagine this dan you know you've
lived in tv your whole life
we have a control room to produce nfl
red zone
and you know those people sit in there
elbow to elbow
we can't do that anymore we've had to
spread out to multiple control rooms
throughout the nfl media campus
and people that are normally used to the
director and technical director sitting
right next to each other the producer
sitting right close there where they've
got that immediate
instant communication they're now in
different parts of the building wearing
headsets
talking to each other talking to me and
hopefully the production hasn't dropped
off much but
if it hasn't it's a testimony to our
amazing technical crew that that
is the best in the business for my money
do you have an understudy
you know people have asked me that
because i'm taking a covid test
once a week right now and if all sudden
i get
i get put to the shelf who goes in
they they do have someone we we had an
earthquake so we do the show in los
angeles we had an earthquake during
it was the pre-season one time and
they're like what if an earthquake hit
and it knocked us off like what would
happen and they told me they have
someone
i i don't even know exactly who but they
have someone at nfl films in new jersey
that could take over
if it was like a los angeles problem
and if it was a scot problem whatever
i'm on the show for some reason
they have someone in los angeles they
could put in hopefully i never find out
their identity
he's a scott hanson nfl network's nfl
red zone host and coming up this weekend
the 200th
show you can watch all seven hours of
live football
and that'll be sunday afternoons
throughout the regular season who do
people
say you look like
okay so you guys were just talking about
him a second ago
ryan tannehill some people say okay now
i'm way older and he's way better
looking
but some people say ryan tanning okay
i see that he he has his head shaved a
lot and one time i shaved my head it was
a
it was a benefit for pediatric cancer
and when i shaved my head my girlfriend
at the time took a photo of me and we
did a
by side with ryan tannehill in it it was
it was not too far off
better looking and much younger i see
stiffler from american pie
oh really yeah yeah i could see a little
stiffler there
okay you know yeah
you're the first person to ever tell me
that i'll take it i'll take that as a
compliment
they they had good numbers on the on the
american pipes and they did yeah they
did quite well
uh we've all had those moments we had
there's nothing
higher than the highs that you get in in
broadcasting and you know i've talked
about some of the things i've been able
to do in my career
but then the lowest of lows
how that hits you like if you had that
lowest of lows
during a broadcast where you went oh my
god and
you can't you there the camera doesn't
blink like you're there and you got to
do it and you got to keep going and
you know you don't get to go i'm going
to go home now have you had that moment
where you go
what did i just do i i've had two
and one was this season because look
i'm doing seven hours live television
all ad-libbed
right and i saturate my brain with
stats facts figures story lines quotes
everything during the week to be as
prepared for sunday as i possibly can
but when we get on live we're winging it
so
i'm dispensing probably thousands if not
tens of thousands of
pieces of information per show i'm gonna
screw up
i'm a human i want my free throw
percentage to be around 99.8
but i'm gonna mess up the other day it
was
two three weeks ago uh ronald jones from
the tampa bay buccaneers got a run
and i called him legarrette blunt
he's wearing 27 he's grown his hair out
he's playing for the buccaneers and my
my my lizard brain
somehow flashed back to like three years
ago
and then and then i'm like oh no no no
no no no no i go i go no no no no i'm
i'm sorry i'm sorry that's leonard
fournette
and and then remember i go like this and
my spotter looks at me like
and i'm like uh yeah it's rojo it's the
main back who's been running for
them for the last like basically two
years and i just i just wanted to cringe
i just wanted to die but
like explain your spotter like the whole
setup you have
because you know play-by-play guy will
have a spotter but you have how many
monitors
and then you have a spotter a stat guy
probably a director a producer in your
ear yeah so well with kovid we've had to
pair things down as well there are only
three people in the studio with me
there is the camera's robotic and it's
actually in a locked down position
so we don't we don't have a camera
operator there's no one else
allowed in the stage manager comes in
when she needs to do her job
but i've got a researcher and a spotter
they both kind of interchange
but they're sitting socially distant
apart but
they'll feed me you know i don't
necessarily i'm not keeping tabs on
oh patrick mahomes has 243 yards passing
in the first half
they'll feed me something when when i
need to know it and
they can do it we have wax boards
they'll write it on a wax board and
throw it up there
they'll put something up on their laptop
and point to the name if i don't
recognize the player who made the play
or they'll just sometimes they'll just
mouth it to me they'll be like you know
you know and i'm like i mean hopefully
it's not tyree
i recognize him readily but they'll give
it they'll give me something hopefully
it doesn't bleed onto my microphone but
i know i know a bit about football but
i'm not i'm not uh
completely on lockdown with every stat
fact and uh roster and depth chart
especially in covid days so i'm so
thankful for those
guys tim tim tim gillian's and uh brian
laravey
who's wayne larabee sun the the great
play-by-play guy for the for the
green bay packers these are my
right-hand men well congrats scott
been a great run for you guys uh 200th
episode coming up this weekend the nfl
red zone and uh
thanks for joining us dan good to be
with you have a great weekend we'll see
you guys sunday that is uh scott hanson
see scott won't see us but we'll see
scott
see scott you screwed up